hey guys what's up I'm here with the
infamous notorious and blabbermouth min
you know I'm doing spectacular this is
thing called the hardware challenge what
you do is you go to a hardware store
find a package that you would like to
redesign I'm holding the energizer
batteries what I selected for min to
redesign so she's come up with a number
of local concepts I'm gonna take you
through the entire process including her
mock-ups how do you start talking to me
about your process something with lots
of speed and energy was this the jumping
off point the springboard for you then
you came up with a lot of words okay so
I'm just gonna read some of the words
electricity passion initiative energy
power + dynamic ultimate infinity speed
why did you come up with words first
because it helps me to brainstorm mm-hmm
images like icons pattern it just helps
me to translate oh okay and how did you
come up with these words by just looking
at the image yeah don't worry this can I
see what are you looking for like how do
you pick this typefaces versus that
typefaces versus another what are you
looking for I look at different shapes
of letter forms mm-hm conveys to figure
elements um trying to go mm-hmm you
started with a base II you got rid of
the vertical stroke and then you offset
it things to kind of see this is quite a
nice shape here because it still reads
as an e and it shows movement because
it's set a slant or an oblique angle I
like the amount of exploration that you
go through just to kind of iterate on
ideas
[Music]
this is something I learned from my type
professor which is when you're exploring
an idea start here and go here and here
and then take steps in between so if
this is the edge of what it can be push
it right to the edge that way your
exploration shows a breadth of ideas and
then I'm also seeing some exploration
here that is very intriguing to me so
here there are three E's in the word
energizer and each one pro gets
progressively gets more and more
extended there's something pretty cool
this is pretty nice exploration here too
you've broken energizer into three lines
they're trying to make it a little bit
block here and there for a little bit
more like an icon sometimes somebody who
isn't working on the project can step
into it and see something that maybe you
didn't like or might have thrown away
and I think it's helpful to kind of have
that kind of dialogue so what what Minh
is saying is she's putting these two
connections together like this and that
to form this alright I think you have a
winner in here too this is very nice
energizer wow this is a lot
[Music]
her name is min but she's very mighty
okay so now you're getting into color
studies so now we reduce them down to
our three favorite right all right so
let's take a look at it I think this
mark is excellent I would use this if I
were a client this one's really cool too
and lastly this is some kind of a hybrid
version of these ideas I think did you
have a favorite oh that's one yes first
yeah it looks like a battery yep so now
let's get into the packaging stuff right
now as I go through these
why do you explore so many different
things cuz sometimes you don't know what
you're doing so part of your process is
just to work through as many designs as
possible until something feels like it's
clicking look how sexy this one is you
guys look at this
[Music]
make sure you know what the primary
piece of communication is since I know
this is energizer the next thing is
going to be to know that it's a 9-volt
battery I don't want to grab the wrong
one and go home and like say darn it we
gotta go back to the hardware store and
buy this again so we have to be careful
about what we're pulling out here the
max sub brand might be important to an
energizer as a company but I need to
know it's a 9-volt battery this one you
cannot miss it it's a 9-volt C it's like
9 volt ok so you clean up the type this
is 100 percent actual size now and
sometimes I'll just keep this next so
you can see how garish this packaging
looks with all these light rays and
energy and how this is so much more
sophisticated it's interesting that when
you put the battery in what it does to
the design so it's why it's very
important to design the battery and put
it in here because we're making
decisions about how much information we
can process ok a question always comes
up man how long did you work on this
process about two weeks that seems about
fair on and off lot of starting stops
I'm pretty sure min could do this in
less time if she wasn't working other
projects right because you would start a
couple days and you get pulled in my
house so here's what min is selected as
her favorite design and then min
designed the battery - which looks
really cool this is the coolest bad I've
ever seen
[Music]
you see the thoroughness in which she's
attacking the problem am in and I shares
some DNA that we both went to art center
and this is very typical of a private
art school education you start with an
image then you go into words then the
words become a type studies and then
type studies become a pretty exhaustive
exploration of a bunch of different
ideas before committing to anything hope
you found this process to be helpful
we've kind of shown you a glimpse into
how somebody like min solves a big
corporate identity project in a
packaging assignment like this let us
know what you guys think thanks for
tuning in see you guys next time
we good all right we're good